alright the big day is here we are
finally doing the Reuben report fan show
in case you missed it a couple weeks
back I had asked you guys to let me know
why I should interview you and I got to
tell you guys you did not disappoint me
we got almost 1200 responses within a
week and ended up selecting 20 of you
instead of the original five that we had
intended oh [ __ ] iud Reuben it's good to
see you oh man it's got better hair than
me I don't want to do this one I'm not
gonna tell them that they're just
misogynist since exits can the sooner
you could say it go crazy you could say
more than that we did our best to pick
an eclectic mix of people from all over
the world oh boy I'm the most um sweetie
sweetie you just could find I didn't
really think anything other than I heard
more explosions if you CJ knows that
kind of like a lot of olive oil avoid it
I'm honored really to have such an
incredible fan base that not only is
connecting with me but with each other
as well and i have been using the
women's restroom for eight years without
any issue now I'm scared in Brazil we
have free health care meaning the
government takes over everything and
that's where exactly where I see people
dying for lack of basic care I know the
value of being a strong independent
woman as cliche as it sounds and that
doesn't involve safe spaces the
first-ever Ruben report fan show is here
let's roll
you